dans ce rythme de vie effréné midi vient
de passer et on n'a pas le temps de
manger et six ans arrêtés on prenait
tout de même une collation à telle heure
c'est vraiment la barre temps total et
donc c'est pas la barre tendre nos
protéines et ainsi une barque est très
riche en oméga 3 en fibres et en faire
il ya présentement plus de la moitié des
consommateurs exige smac et utiliser des
collations plus de deux fois par jour il
ya de plus en plus de gens qui auront
une alimentation des structures et ça
veut dire moins de report for mais elle
est beaucoup plus de collations beaucoup
plus de entre les repas beaucoup plus
d'aliments qu'on était à la volée dans
une journée
l'industrie développe de plus en plus de
produits dans ce marché canadien de 4
milliards de dollars
une nouvelle gamme de collations dit
santé apparaît des lentilles et les pois
chiches assaisonné de la pâte de fruits
boules d'énergie tout pour combler notre
appétit
on nous propose des solutions qui sont
tout aussi pratique quel sera mon sac
bärtschi pour une palette de chocolat
mais qui nous offre un apport
alimentaire et les patins du supérieur
[Musique]
qu'on a des petits airs un peu partout
nous dans la province originaire de la
côte nord caroline doit faire beaucoup
de route elle en avait assez de manger
trop souvent de la malbouffe l'a eu
l'idée de créer sa propre marque de
collations santé
on avait rarement l'option de bien
manger sur la route dont on se rendait
compte que avec toutes nos contraintes
alimentaires et tout et tout les goût de
tout le monde on finissait toujours avec
un sac de chips des bonbons c'était
toujours de la restauration rapide non
sur la chemin y avait pas beaucoup
d'options
donc de là est née l'idée de ma soeur et
moi de rendre disponibles des collations
santé des aliments sur le pouce
disponible pour les gens c'est à québec
dans son petit atelier ils sont
confectionnés tous ces produits ils
seront par la suite vendus dans plus de
100 points de vente
ici on retrouve nos bocaux pour la
livraison dans les points de vente
zéro déchet les points de vente
spécialisés dans le vrai également pour
déshydrater aujourd'hui aux prêteurs
déclaré à la voix ni aux framboises
on est vraiment allé chercher des
produits le plus simple possible
on offre des barres tendres qui sont
faits à base de céréales de soya pour
l'instant mais on cherche en fait à
enrichir de protéines une barre tendre
avec toujours nous menu d'ingrédients le
plus simple possible
la plupart des collations dit santé sur
le marché sont en grande majorité
composée d'ingrédients à base de
végétaux soya légumineuses noix graines
des protéines alternative souvent
présenté en petites bouchées pour être
plus pratique s'est posté dur ou mou
chez nous
comme un petit parc de fruits en
compagnie de la nutritionniste stéphanie
côté l'épicerie analyser une trentaine
de collations de toutes sortes
cette nouvelle offre est très
intéressante il dirait entre autres pour
la qualité des ingrédients la naturalité
des ingrédients il ya moins d'aliments
transformés qu'est ce qu'on a l'habitude
de retrouver dans dans la grande
catégorie des collations fille ya
quelques années on voyait beaucoup de
marketing autour du 100 calories là
c'est pas tant les chiffres qui sont mis
de l'avant que la valeur des ingrédients
utilisés
cette naturalité et bien en évidence sur
les emballages
il ya beaucoup d'ingrédients que nous
sont présentés comme des super aliments
le chien par exemple la cameline même le
sucre de canne et quand c'est écrit
comme sucre de campbell le fabricant
souhaite nous faire avaler que ceux du
meilleur sucre mais ça reste du sud je
pense pour rester critique vis-à-vis les
listes d'ingrédients et les allégations
qu'on fait à l'égard de certains
ingrédients propos les mettre sur un
piédestal des ingrédients sains mais une
pomme un fruit une poignée de noix sont
tout autant pratique et facile à manger
et surtout économique
on prétendra jamais être plus 5 juste un
fruit ou juste un légume on vient
compléter le fruit est le légume des
noix on en offre ici évidemment et de
même que par exemple pour remplacer les
noix pourquoi pas des pois chiches
pourquoi pas des lentilles les
consommateurs aiment la variété c'est à
nous aider même chose alors même si
santé mangez une pomme et des noix dans
la tendance à chercher de la variété là
dedans aussi et plus ça prend la place
d'un report
plus on a besoin que ce soit complet en
volume et un groupe alimentaire on
cherche une collation mais qui
remplacera pas une collation pour chaque
période la journée ou pour chaque
activité qu'on va faire un fruit c'est
pas nécessairement toujours suffisant
quand on s'en va par exemple le centre
et nick qu'on n'a pas mangé depuis 4h
japonnais serment nous soutenir assez
souvent ça va même ouvrir l'appétit
donc dans le fond on essaie de venir
ajouté et compléter cette offre selon
stéphanie côté il est important de
connaître nos besoins afin de mieux
choisir je dirais que tout les
collations ne sont pas aussi bonnes pour
toutes les personnes par exemple pour
des sportifs on va rechercher davantage
les collations qui sont faits avec soit
des céréales ou encore des fruits et des
dattes ou d'autres fruits séchés parce
qu'on a besoin de glucides quand on fait
du sport c'est le principal carburant de
notre corps quand on est allé fort 6e
des protéines et des fibres alimentaires
ça c'est des aliments font se digérer
plus lentement et qui vont nous
permettre d'attendre jusqu'au prochain
repas après 60 ans va être à faire
les sachets de la seoul et lupin ou
encore les pois chiches grillé ce n'est
que c'est là une collation pour le
bureau pour les enfants à l'école
et si la bouche et faciles à manger le
sac est facile à vider et les calories
peuvent rapidement s'accumuler
si on mange on est en train de
travailler ou de conduire on n'a pas
conscience de ce qu'on est en train de
manger donc ça peut-être être dedans
par exemple ce petit sac de lentilles
contient autant de protéines que repas
l'intérêt des collations qui contiennent
des protéines ce que ça nous aide à
répartir les protéines durant la journée
donc à mieux avoir avant une énergie
plus soutenu au fil de la journée à
avoir moins de baisse d'énergie avant la
collation c'était un truc était 100%
impulsif c'est on avait faim on mêle à
la machine distributrice ou deux au café
en bas au dépanneur ont ramassé quelque
chose aujourd'hui la collation et elle
est beaucoup plus elle est beaucoup plus
planifiés alors c'est pour ça qu'on a
des collations dit santé de façon
organisée tellement organisé que des
entreprises nous propose de commander
nos collation en ligne un clic et une
boîte de différentes collation nous est
livré
on s'est dit pourquoi ne pas offrir
encore plus d'alternative en distribuant
d'autres gammes de produits donc des
produits de d'autres compagnies
plusieurs de ces collations rejoignent
donc les préoccupations actuelles des
consommateurs
pratique facile bonne pour nous bonne
pour la planète mais il faut savoir bien
les choisir
[Musique]